hello and welcome to this video playing
oddball harm yeah he's a London system
player let's see what to do here against
this put this video against their five
still goes Bishop f4 it's very likely I
just one okay this is a bitchin bit more
ambitious why can take platform I should
have gone d 5 hmm this is not not a
great thing to play but ok let's see how
he handles this very solid very solid
game ok I try to bring the it's always
95 is the thing this is extremely tough
to do something against ok it's not
threatening to take I can always play
which it takes d4 at the end I don't
know what to say just think i think i
can do now I really have to hear that i
have control of age five
yeah night 55 maybe okay I have to go
back to ch I looking for is the kind of
movie want to play here it's just
completely nonsensical yet as white can
what never has to take I mean if he does
take I've got it I've got a good game
but it's not really a necessary move and
come it's too tempting it's just
attempting to play taking is really also
i think but I ball maybe you can but be
5v5 is a good movement then push me back
with it just it was just too tempting to
places ok so I do this and now the
problem is I have to go back and see but
it's so it's not so easy for him to take
this i mean i get good activity if he
does on the on the King side
what takes takes 90 to an official page
41 either fire and it's not really
correct but if you can play mcfly group
before and it is somewhat reasonable and
I should always feel too tempted to do
it it's not it's not so easy with why
then you kind of feel you should take it
but you also know that it won't be that
easy I mean objectively can take it I
didn't want to take it okay so he wants
to play a three-year probably chef cook
edge for unfortunately doesn't do much
good yes so let's be six or something
and now it takes again you can only
tempt people for small Valley at one
point they feel too tempted and they
have to take it and it's to it sir it's
a good decision and Bishop takes maybe
an idea
no this is a good move I mean it's just
a good ol so I wonder if I want to
provoke this stuff or not yes I think I
want to do that look at the F to him for
potential III or just clean up for Queen
aphorism is somewhat of a threat even
though well looky to cover stuff so now
that neither this doesn't do much on the
night so let's bring the night over here
to h4 and so on that's a good move
trading training trading so III and know
him I don't know if we also the kind of
thing that can easily be too quick in
releasing the tension what your can
anyway after have to do something
okay that was a good move i think
pinning me down makes it difficult to
get everything in the game not quite
sure i'm actually threatening something
to be honest maybe bishop h4 awesome and
then take on it it's really it's all a
bit hazy well this is this i don't
believe g3 Bishop takes does that work
for white I don't quite believe k and
night h4 looks right but something else
no I have to do this it's not easy now
I'm threatening to take their and i
think i will take them and now queen g3
doesn't do the job this is bloody hook
there is deeply deeply annoying i think
i just go back and plan for the Queen
comin over here Queen coming over like
this 495 this
Greenidge form check-in age four and now
I can just take the hook this is
probably best quite recently Jeff it was
probably not entirely correct but it was
pretty dangerous I think I mean looking
for is the move that is probably not
going to be enough that that's not going
to be approved by the engine but it's
very tempting to claim I think up to
this point it is very logical and I
think the engines the valuation of
roughly equal is probably right I have
the bishop am a bishop 1c8 however done
we look good but I happy five under
control is what the queen-sized players
must be roughly equal and this is the
kind of move again if i don't quite
quite believe that it is objectively
good but now you'll see that the engine
is not pleased giving plus 2 or
something like that it is somewhat
playable I mean some captures don't work
at all of course because of forks and I
mean this kind of thing I have some
compensation now a total bishop pair
there is f2 there's space on the king
size yeah it's not enough but it's
interesting the engine wants to give
materials back again I mean something
like that I think that's going to be
dangerous not so easy again objectively
maybe not but it was interesting yeah
something like that I think I didn't
think of 96 that look strange and now
this is he has to go g3 I mean you know
the light squares and
the minor pieces are pretty good it's
possible and now we've decided to take
it i mean i think the engine is
definitely correct them give it give
that back give that back nope here watch
expression okay seven ok didn't see
orgasm I've got two pawns and roock
against two minor pieces this is that is
also much easier to play than this
position now and now it's a good
compensation and tough to play and after
f3 I think it's basically gone and then
it can't really take us far too strong
yeah I this was probably not the best
Queen f4 yeah I want to edit I did
absolutely wanted to keep the porn this
is this should i take the three okay but
night at 52 so tricky tweenage 4 + 93
aunt and so on that's just too much yeah
and will be for North kind of awesome if
you see them and feel like their work
somewhat it's you should try out they're
just fun to do ok guys thanks for
watching